كلها اسماء لشخص واحد
ذلك الجاسوس الذي كانت رسائله الوارده
لمقر المخابرات الامريكيه بمثابه ليله عيد
لعملاء المكتب الفيدرالي فما قصته ولد
ديميتري بولياكوف عام
1921 لعائله متواضعه في اوكرانيا حيث عمل
والده محاسبا والتحق بالمدرسه العسكريه
وفاز باوسمه الشجاعه كضابط مدفعيه خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه قبل ان تجنده
وكاله المخابرات السوفييتيه وترسله الى
نيويورك ضمن البعثه السوفييتيه لدى الامم
المتحده خلال فتره الخمسينيات من القرن
الماضي تولى بوليا كوب مهمه توجيه
الجواسيس السوفيتي الذين عملوا هناك دون
غطاء دبلوماسي لكنه ايضا كان شاهدا على
الفساد الذي عانى منه الاتحاد السوفيتي
لينمو بداخله كره عميق للنظام السوفيتي في
ذلك الوقت في عام
1961 اتصل بوليا كوف بالسفاره الامريكيه
في موسكو دون الكشف عن هويته مع عرض
لمساعدتهم كجاسوس وبدا في تقديم معلومات
استخباريه لهم لا تقدر بثمن حول برامج
تطوير الصواريخ السوفييتيه والقدرات
العسكريه والخطط ضد الصين كالبيانات
الفنيه عن الصواريخ السوفييتيه المضاده
للدبابات التي ساعدت القوات الامريكيه على
التعامل مع تلك الاسلحه بعد سنوات كما سرب
اسماء ضباط عسكريين امريكيين وبريطانيين
يعملون كجواسيس للاتحاد السوفيتي وقدم
ادله على العداء الذي تكنه بكين تجاه
موسكو الذي استغله الرئيس نيكسون للتظاهر
بالانفتاح على الصين في عام 1972
خلال اكثر من عشرين عاما من عمله لدى
المخابرات الامريكيه منح مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي ديمتري اسم توبهات كما منح
اسماء اخرى اثناء مهماته المختلفه مثل
دونالد ديربين روم قبل ان يصبح مستشارا
لعملاء المخابرات الامريكيه ويوصف بانه
جوهره تاج وكاله المخابرات المركزيه في
عام 1980 تم استدعاء بوليا كوفي الى موسكو
ثم اختفى عن الانظار تماما حتى ذكرت صحيفه
الحزب الشيوعي الرسمي في عام 1990 انه ضبط
متلبسا بالتجسس وتم اسره وحكم عليه
بالاعدام لم يعرف احد كيف مات بولياكوف او
اين دفن ولكن خيانته سجلت كعلامه ناجحه في
دار اشتعال الحرب اكثر والحفاظ على
استمراريه الحرب البارده
وحفظها من الغليان